i want to say thank you for supporting
me
in my ability to be a human
i love you and i want to let you know
that the tour
is still unnamed i'll name it soon by
next week i think i'll have a name for
it
but it's coming to uh st louis
cincinnati
good places charlotte durham
chattanooga knoxville
wilmington you want to get out there in
wilmington where people are a lot of
milk maids out there
wilkes-barre minneapolis
charleston richmond baltimore over there
the black main they call it
portland burlington albany buffalo
columbus ohio
as well uh the um
the netflix taping those shows are sold
out in nashville thank you so much for
the support
and i will be running that material in
huntsville a few days prior
that is the first week of august you can
get tickets for any date
at theovonn.com tour
don't buy through any other link it's a
scam
these jacked up prices i try to keep
tickets at fair prices for you
today's guest is a friend of mine a
decent man
and a man who has walked the road of uh
we've walked a very common road when it
comes to humor and
and that's a wrote a struggle
he's become a better friend of mine over
the past year and
we have a lot in common and we're going
to get into some of that
and uh-huh and just talk turkey about to
embark on his fresh cuts
comedy tour it is mr
john chris
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
that's just the lord's liquid right
there bro it ain't nothing to it
liquid death man i don't know if i'd
want to go with a dry death or a liquid
death
to die now what do you do now you have a
you got a real religious kind of history
you know
tell me about that like how do you kind
of because sometimes
sometimes i feel like you get not
penciled in with religion
yeah but you almost you know matthew
mark luke and john chris
you know like it's not shocking to hear
that they were like or if i
did that joke in my show you'd be like
oh this is like his like
this is part of the thing you're right
but
what i mean if you well if you live in
america
let's say an average person's because i
grew up in church my dad's pastor
i was homeschooled really yeah
homeschooled
one of eight kids wow so when you
so did your dad teach any of the courses
or in homeschooling is the
is the the mother the mom teaches the
mom
well well see there's two types of home
school there's like home school like if
you're
serena williams and you want to be
professional football or you want to be
a professional tennis player like i'll
just homeschool so i can
and then there's like the cultural
homeschoolers those are like long jean
skirts
christian traditionally that's a
different type of homeschool like pail
of water
yeah that's a here's like where did they
go when they got fried they got a faucet
but they got one right yeah books around
the belt you know
yeah yeah very willian nelly olsen from
a little house on the prairie
is that how it go you're like nah not
really but sure yeah yeah yeah
so with homeschooling man so your mother
homeschooled you
yeah did your dad does the dads come up
with the curriculum
where did they get the curriculum
it's you like have a like there's like a
there's like a group they have like
their home school like textbooks
it's like but that but you buy all the
textbooks but then you use them eight
times because my brother
did it and then i do it two years later
and then the little brother
but all the like a math problem would be
like
i wish i was making this up but i'm not
in matthew 4 he had five loaves and two
fish subtract
three loaves how many you they're all
like the
they're about the bible right like all
the it's not like a train was traveling
60 miles an hour like a caravan of
donkeys going to see the north star
oh okay so it suddenly like gets it in
there you know what i'm saying like okay
we'll slide the bible in
what they'll sneak some facts in huh
that's true
yeah we'll teach them dude one way or
another did you guys
like at halloween because i dated a girl
for a little bit no halloween in my
house dude from nashville right
and she at halloween they were only
allowed to dress up
as characters from the bible oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and she was growing up well so do you
know what she dressed as
i don't know who she dressed as i think
it was one of the women in it
here's the thing about the bible kind of
dude heavy yeah they're all written by
dudes
yeah yeah yeah and the educated guys
which is a
a little tricky brenda should have got
him yeah
at least a book hey this is how i you
know i used to have a joke in my show
about there there was a story in the
bible about jesus and the prostitute
that's the that's the heading of the
story uh-huh
and you know the prostitute she gets her
sins forgiven and she gets saved and all
this kind of stuff
she's in heaven now this is my bit but
like
she was like yo what's up my name's like
cheryl or like who i'm like
depressed oh what's up dude you're the
okay like she didn't she get a name
wow she gets no name so when the bible
didn't even give her a name
no but there's that's not gender
specific there's like jesus and the man
with leprosy
he's like dude i had a nice job i had a
family i
right i had more than leprosy but for
the book it's like we just need you to
be leprosy
we need you to be leprosy one there's no
uh
we need prostitute one we need leprosy
one what's it called when you do a tv
show and then
somebody's in the background doing
something like hey can you oh yeah
release there
there was no release at the back in the
bible times about leprosy guys like hey
we're just gonna
right we're just gonna take your story
bro and leprosy was pretty popular i
think for a while
you know and if you were if you were if
you had it it was
it was bad no you're out you you can't
oh you can't party with leopards
no no no no but i don't even know if
that's how it was transmitted but that
in
you know they're just like you're cast
out if you got the i don't know what is
it what do you think it is a scab or
something party i think it was like a
little
something and then your whole body it
got like your leg would
fall off i don't think you would shed a
limb yeah you want to look at a police
on leprosy
bring up a limb shedding what is
but that when you talk about something
bad in the bible like dude he probably
probably had left leprosy infectious
disease called babasalus
so i don't know who he is that who that
is he uh transmitted via droplets
that sounds familiar yeah nose
from the nose of the mouth there's no
masks back then bro wow
the basilis is likely transmitted via
droplets yup
it's curable with therapy
there were there were two 202
who registered cases of leprosy in 2019.
what if you called a girl hey i can't
come over tonight
why not i got leprosy
that would it'd be like i mean it says
right there two hundred two thousand
cause it's plausible
but it's not i guess it doesn't it's not
a death sentence now it's plausible
but if you if you were like you walking
into something and you rolled an ankle
back in the bible you're like
that's it that's it that's it if you
roll the net yeah like
you walk in with a limp the rest of your
that's it well we forget you know i i
i i will romanticize things a lot of
times and think man
you know it'd be so nice to be on a
carriage with my wife or with something
like you know
yeah yeah and like old times like old
times i'll do that a lot
yeah yeah yeah and then you start to
think like what old times were really
like and it was probably pretty sad
tough
well you don't have to go back that far
to like
if you think about like dude when you
were a kid remember going
to pick someone up at the airport you
just like
i hope they're here oh yeah and you go
around
circle back around you're like maybe
they're here this time right and then
you would just
there was no check in this there's no
flight tracker there's no cell phones
you just went you would keep going yeah
maybe you stay for 30 minutes and then
and if you were there with your
that he'd send you in hey run in there
and see on the on the screen
yeah if it's here and but you don't even
know if he got on it
right because you can't call but it was
also so much fun i feel like to just go
do anything then it was like
yeah everything was kind of like an
adventure it was like all right let's go
we're going to pick up our friend from
the airport
what's going to happen right they were
going to go up there to meet some
so-and-so in the movie theater maybe
but maybe not he might not be there yeah
if your date didn't show like you really
got stood up like you like there was no
way to like
know why or to say is they could lie
it was easy next time they saw they
could lie but remember when i
remember i told you a couple days ago
about when you i didn't get a text back
from me and then you it went to green
and i was like
that's a red alert in 2021 right but
back then he'd be like
he'll turn back up and say like he
missed a week a couple weeks of school
what happened to him
yeah and then you show back up what's up
dude he's around yeah
i don't know he's cutting the ground
yeah where'd he been yeah you don't know
i don't know
now it's like so much such a mystery
then there were so many people
but now it's like the like you know
girls be like
hey i noticed you don't watch my
instagram stories anymore you're like oh
my
okay we know too much yeah wouldn't you
say that like oh now it's definitely
like oh i saw you like on your instagram
about i don't need to
probably know that yeah and you can't
hide anymore you can't
like i used to love to be able to make
things up back in the day
you could make up who your family yeah
yeah anything you
can't anymore you could say you were a
prince you could make up anything
he was like you're a prince dude you
know you couldn't change that you
couldn't exactly
check anything small big bird sweatshirt
okay little question i don't feel like a
prince would wear that why you moved
here to louisiana yeah but it's kind of
like we had a transfer situation but
they were like all right
yeah it was an exchange program at the
castle that's like dude
and you know in rehab you can't you
can't
no one knows you don't have any phones
or nothing so no one knows you can make
up stuff there
right because this guy said he's from
india and he's like he had like
this is true actually like 37 like
not servants at his house but 37 people
worked at his house
no way and you're like that's a
different but you don't know anybody's
name
they don't know their whole name oh if i
was any it might be like
chuck right you're like i don't know he
might i don't know
maybe chuck has 37 people working for
him
oh damn chuck's heart is up
um here's a question right here from
somebody that came in
theo vaughn's my favorite comedian in
the whole world it's more choice by the
way and john crist
is my wife's favorite comedian in the
whole world
i wouldn't like the white i feel like
the universe is about to implode
how did you guys connect was it the
nashville thing
did you guys know about each other
coming up
and john what's it like for you to be on
theo's podcast
like is this it for you you gonna blow
now just like the big
this is it not gonna blow me dude you
know what i'm saying no
no no i mean
i'm not trying to knock you or anything
but okay first of all we gotta hang with
that guy
that everything about that i don't know
the guy is shirtless
he was like before i get to my question
i need to get some
i need to be involved and right we had a
lot of backstory
sometimes i get nervous and take my
shirt off when i do stuff
i don't like to be shirtless you don't
um
i just got to make sure your my body's
positioned right when you're shirtless
oh really when you're sitting up like
this you know what i'm saying you don't
look good
oh that you know what it's like your
body looks a little yeah that's like
kind of like i've been drinking step dad
yeah yeah
i wonder who came uh someone that came
up with shirts everybody hey we gotta
i wonder why it all goes back to i think
how like i
like even romanticizing what things used
to be like like it was probably so
hot people were so stinky yeah that's
the thing you don't realize someone was
horrible dude people were stinky people
were dying like hey do you want to marry
you know uh you gotta go down to the
river it might be three and a half miles
away you want to marry sarah
there wasn't any options for marriage i
was like do you want to marry margaret
because that's who you're
there was no like that's why they say
like hey there's only
you know very very like a religious
christian there's like you're there
you have a soul mate one person on this
planet
for you that god has a plan for you to
find this woman
one person on planet earth is seven
billion people right and it happened to
be the girl that lives two doors down i
know what are the odds of that out of
that
wow this girl actually worked in my
office she worked in your office
and you what seven billion people on
earth and the girl that was god's plan
for you
worked in your office y'all are lucky
wow
dang god had the easiest thing dude
that's the
easiest plan yo that's a hookup dude you
found her just you didn't even have to
go
man you barely had to leave the state
you didn't have to leave the
neighborhood she was right there
you can't really say that's like not
very romantic to say that there's a
bunch of women
that would be good for you
well i'm married but that's would be
true right right
well i don't know like how many do you
think
would be a good marriage partner for you
let's say
i think it's time okay i'm the loose
nugget so
you might cut down you might do five
thousand
in america in the world in the world oh
wow
that's a good amount five thousand but
then if you say
babe you're the only one for me she's
like i mean
that's a hefty promise but it used to be
of reliable it used to be a fair promise
to make
i think to someone that you're the one
for me and now part of the problem is
there's
so many ones well there's also so many
like
ability there's so much capability to
get access
it's like yeah you know they say you're
only as
capable as your options or whatever like
you don't yeah
yeah all of a sudden you get some money
your
sphere kind of you can get outside of
the neighborhood a little bit
right yeah all of a sudden you got a
driver's license now you can
right you can go to the next town you
could get across town you could touch
titty across
town i remember back in the day you
realize
it you had your did you ever like
intermix with the other high schools
like you were you just kind of hang in
your high school no i would hang at the
other high schools because i ended up
switching from one school to another
like
in two different towns they were totally
different one was like a real country
town
that i grew up in and one was a little
bit more like suburban
like kind of rich you were welcome both
of them
yeah well when i got to the fancier one
that's the first time a girl ever liked
me
and so it was i had like a new beginning
when what you what age
what grade um seven
eight nine ten grade yeah yeah yeah i
remember walking across the gym and some
girl was looking at me and i thought
something happened to me you know what
i'm saying
like you might have glowed up yeah i had
a summer you might have to glow up
somewhere i might have maybe got your
braces off or something like that oh
no i needed braces so it must have been
like this kind of make a wishy type yeah
yeah
but her name was jenny i remember she
was hot man and she looked
she looked that was the first time you
ever remember a girl looking at you like
in a way
dude i can still feel her looking at me
that's how that's how
nice it was to be admired by a woman you
might have been
we're still chasing that oh it might be
i think i'm still chasing that
admiration
did we answer that other guys question
was a question i mean we met i think i
mean i've known about you over the years
but i've seen you more so
i know where i met you we've talked
about this before
at uh the punch line in atlanta and i
did a guest spot for you
did you really yeah oh wow you were
wearing sweatpants
you were wearing elastic sweatpants i
got this man is unhinged oh wow but you
were just you came in you're like what
up
oh nobody dude what's crazy about now
with me and you and then is like
we ate like no one knew who we were
right no one was like trying like we
were trying to
hang with fans like we were trying they
were like nah we good remember those
days
oh like we would be like what are y'all
doing right and that would be like yeah
we're good
yeah and that wasn't that long ago like
i got a family man i got a future they
were like hey y'all want to like
drink or something they're like no dude
we like we like like your hamster bone
story but we gotta go
yeah dude we wanted fun to see if you
had a couple of free hamps out here yeah
we're good dude they had good pie at
that place that yeah
great pie the new punch line yeah the
new punch line but dude but but
what's funny about that guy's comment is
what you always have is like
you're my favorite comedian and i'm his
wife's favorite comedian
ooh it's like that that's very common
for you and i were at that bar one night
remember yeah and some guy
said didn't some guy said my wife loves
you
which i don't is that good or bad i
don't know i would trade you
i'm joking with that guy specifically i
mean maybe without no one specific not
knowing his wife not even knowing being
like sight unseen that's a good call
i'll take it
oh well you know ralphie may ralphie may
said
rip he said women
are the ones that that that you know if
you have like a little like a sexist
like misogynistic joke
people are like yeah like first of all
women make the decision to come see you
guys will come but no like you know
those real like
old school type comics that were very
like like
that's not a thing and like women are
driving the sales
and if you're cool to women you're
that's like you know like only
exclusively dude comics you know that
any of those guys
i don't know they're the good crowd my
audience is male 1 yours
yeah yeah so what do you think from like
the
like the fighting stuff no i think just
from podcasting just talking about stuff
being alive a lot of money is just men
that are trying to be alive
trying to live i think yeah do you know
have you ever looked at your instagram
like you're the break
down yeah i'm like 80
man i'm the exact opposite really that
is wild
no exact opposite which i got a little
bit i feel a little bit
i feel some kind of way about that but
you feel some kind of way about yours
no i feel honestly i just feel grateful
that i found that i have
some sort of connection with an audience
yeah so i think that that's
really the most imp that's that's kind
of what feels
like that i mean yes i think every
comedian wishes there was like a bunch
of big
juggy bro bro uh that you're looking at
your demographics and they have photos
oh this is this is it some brassy
muppets in the front dude you know what
i'm saying
i don't think but yeah maybe but uh
the big dude i remember the biggest
breasts i ever saw as a kid was on this
buddy
on a guy on a guy dude i remember even
touching myself to him once when i was
young
because it was the only ones we had at
that age he's but what you saw him
oh i do you sure what do you mean out
he slept with him you know shirtless or
whatever i think it was real hot he was
at that weight where it gets real hot
yeah yeah yeah because hot so easily oh
yeah he's at that hot weight dude you'd
see his uh
you know you'd see the and he had dude
his dad
had done the ceiling fan in his room and
this thing was
illegally powered yes it was on high
yeah it was and you'll turn it off it
doesn't turn off yeah
just yeah there's no off you've seen
those ones that are like is that going
to fall off this like
it's going this one smelled very i think
it ran on kerosene or something it was
really
it was authentic man but i remember the
wind would
cool would almost put a redness on tint
on his skin
okay yeah and he would rest and i
remember one time just being of age at
his house to be erect and just
and he was he was asleep thank god you
were sleeping in the same room with this
man
yeah or he was a yeah yeah yeah and i
don't call him a man we were both boys
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah because i don't
want to be some boy
waiting to a man well the very yeah yeah
well you know when you were like
you're like me talking about this well
when you were like
young you were like you wanted to i
wanted to be like me and my buddies
would like
like streak through the neighborhood yes
and it was cool to be like with your
clothes off
yeah it wasn't really yeah yeah no no it
was very like
and that's the tricky like when we like
in rehab you kind of do your uh
like your sexual history they talk about
that kind of stuff like what's the first
time
you had like a sexual anything oh really
and i remember
when i was i had to be seven or eight
this older girl
came to babysit us and i we were playing
freeze tag and i tagged her on the boob
but i didn't know you know
i didn't know i didn't know much i
didn't know why i wanted to do that
but i just did did you so after you did
it did you
fee did it feel like it felt
unbelievable yeah yeah
and i don't know and that that's god bro
but i don't
it's my penis that's the way everyone's
here everyone is here because of that
right everybody's here because of sex
right so it's yeah that sex becomes this
taboo thing
that's what yeah like louis c.k had a
bit when he came through zany's like
two three weeks ago you gonna watch him
yeah wow yeah
he said i was out of town you
know we take things too far and people
do stuff that's across the line but he
said you
everyone wants to live in a world where
sarah at your high school went what's up
with theo
yeah you right yeah and now you don't
want to go be
touching people inappropriate they're
going across but you want to live in a
world where
someone goes i wonder what she's up to
yeah
right yeah and what's her name um you
know steph curry
yeah yeah so his wife a man yeah grown
man
his wife you know before kids when he
was coming into the league he she said
she would always walk through
you know the you know the hallways and
people would holler at her and be like
what's up and then she said she had two
kids
kind of like got a little bit older she
said
i miss people like kind of
cat calling yeah no no again not not
inappropriate you don't but you
like let's not act like that world
doesn't exist right right
and it is flattering huh what's up like
i wonder what
i want to talk to her right that
whatever that is some see a sense of
attraction
yeah yeah we all want to be wanted in
some way
and then i don't think it's weird to be
you know to be wanted sexually kind of
you know at all really it's but and it
also is the most natural thing like i
get a feeling sometimes in my body
that every part of me wants to climb out
of my penis
you got to go inward first and then
right yeah i literally have a feeling
sometimes like i just get this
like yeah this tense energy that
everything i
have or am i wants to like if my whole
body could
fly out of my hands and just disappear
then
and i'm done anyway we had a good run
you know and that and i feel like i'd be
okay with that what happened to theo you
know what it's a long
story but he won he's on top yeah he's
with the lord now he went out how he
wanted to go
out because it's also interesting if
that's the way that you went out
it'd be like an inverse of the way that
you came in in a weird way
yeah yeah because everybody came into
this world the same way
yeah and it was that's the that's the
real lion king that's the circle of life
right there
yeah it should be some guy masturbating
off a cliff you know what i'm saying
but somebody else catching and taking
care of it
well if you were like that because they
they would talk about how like is it
like a is this like when you were like
you know when you're with your buddies
and you're like let's like sleep
naked or something like that yeah they
were like was that inappropriate and
they were like
no that was just a a
a boy seriously trying yeah yeah and
they were like they want to make a
distinction between because
if they're if it it's a little bit
graphic not really but like if it's two
boys being curious
versus a boy and an uncle because he
knows
right and then that's a problem that's
trauma right when you have the no when
one of them when one of them knows and
is trying to do a thing
first if it's like because and then kids
get in trouble for stuff
that is just curious right don't put
that in the same category
because then that shame comes in like oh
i thought i was
you're supposed to be a christian and
you're streaking like that's it
right that's kind of what you or like
you're going to go jump in the girls
pool and you're going to
that's kind of just but that's a tough
line because then
sometimes it can yeah switch into oh i
don't think that was
that wasn't appropriate right it can
switch
yeah yeah yeah it's true i mean some of
that stuff's tricky dude i remember
babysitting my
ma some family members one time or semi
family
and the kids over there in the bed you
know naked with his little buddy
yeah yeah two boys yeah and so i just
i didn't say nothing to him or make him
feel weird or anything you know
i didn't know i also didn't go in and
tickle him at that moment
it's like you got to know when to tickle
people and when it just let them be
you know that's they say how do you know
i think you just gotta that's something
that's something you know that's you
know but i think people's
that governor inside of your head for
what's okay sexually can
certainly get altered yep yeah and get
uh
like when i think of those duggar kids
like the speaking of religious families
like they have those duggar children you
know they're famous
they're like 10 kids yeah 20 children
how many children was it
pull up duggar i was going to try it
one of my buddies was like friends with
them and i was like going to try to like
date one of them
yeah but they're like that seems like a
good wholesome thing but they
got it got twisted up right there's lots
of stuff there but how i think could you
not at this point you have children the
age is so different
19 kids and counting so you have kids i
mean
you can't even reach a light switch
without touching another kid's breast
you know what i'm saying like you can't
even there's just there's not 19 showers
in that house right i know that there's
not 19
you everyone can't get a hot shower
right let's just that's just the facts
there's going to be a lot of like
passing through in the restaurant yeah
there's a lot of can i get skimly
squeeze by
right there's a lot of them can i shower
with you there's gonna be a lot of that
yeah which is first of all really normal
for kids but then it can get weird when
one of the kids is
now is 16 and one of the kids is five it
can get a little bit weird so if you say
like cause then
wasn't there a lot of like incest and
stuff going on there i think there was
just a lot of like
the one guys had a lot of trouble with
sex sex addiction josh duggar
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah but i just and
i i don't know where it comes from i
haven't read enough into it
uh but wouldn't you wouldn't you like if
sight unseen if someone told you that
story you'd be like
yeah that checks out it makes sense you
know what i'm saying like yeah makes
sense
all right yeah yeah yeah i could have
yeah
um what so when you went to rehab when
you say rehab what kind
what do you go in for i mean i let's see
because i'm in half of them yeah i said
they put me with
for five things because they were like
they like diagnose you so i just went in
there because i was just like
i was drinking a ton i was real sad
i was real sad on the road and i like
i just wanted to get like get out i just
wanted to
we talked about this before the scary
thing is like everybody
we go to dinner tonight everybody at the
restaurant is hoping
for a better tomorrow right maybe if i
get a job maybe if i get a
wife maybe if i get a raise maybe if i'm
in the lottery tomorrow
is going to be better maybe if my
president gets elected
and i was hoping in all these things and
then i got them all oh i had
money i had attention from women i had
all my shows were sold
this is it's unbelievable and that's the
saddest
because you realize oh the hope is not
here
you were hoping in all the better
everybody at the oh yeah
the restaurant has a better faith
because you're like one day i might get
it
and you can live your whole day your
whole life hoping right
and then if you get it and you're still
sad
that's very this it's it's that's
nowhere to go
yeah there's nowhere to go i can relate
to that man yeah
here's something new you know how the
price of gold has been all
over the place lately it's high it's low
it's low it's high oh where is it oh i
want gold
well there's a new way to buy gold
through a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to
gold bars for as little as 30 dollars a
month
you pay each month and once your gold
stash reaches the price of their gold
bars
they discreetly ship you
acre gold to your house
just recently acres introduced the new
100 a month subscription
to a 5 gram gold bar cop them grams
with acre taking physical delivery of
your gold means it's safe and sound
and in your hands that's right acre gold
is also a fantastic hedge against
inflation
which we're already seeing with gas
lumber and food prices
scary times but the big takeaway here is
that you don't have to come out of
pocket all at once
visit get acre gold.com
theo start investing in physical gold
today make sure
you go to this url because acre is
giving away a gold bar
thanks willy wonka to qualify for the
giveaway tweet or post why
you should be the recipient and mention
at acre underscore gold again that's
get acre gold dot com slash theo thank
you acre gold
for supporting the show some some
sometimes you look at your head and you
said damn what happened
what happened to my damn head or you see
a buddy's head you said damn my buddy's
head not doing well
he's a bad farmer his crops have left
them
well keeps can help keeps can help you
keep that bouffant hairline
you know i care about it two out of
three men
will experience some form of hair loss
by the time they are 35.
don't let it be you and if it is stop it
in its tracks
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
low-cost
treatments start at just 10 bucks a
month and keeps offers generic versions
as well yes
yes discreet packaging
take care of what you have if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss do what i did go to keeps.com
theo to get
and receive your first month of
treatment for free that's right that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash t-h-e-o to get your first
month
free k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash theo this stuff is effective take
care
of your hair uh here's a question right
here that came in from somebody
hey theo hey john i am jenna from
minneapolis
and seeing you both live can't hide
okay hide money she said um
anyway i have a question for both of you
actually you have
both been pretty open and vulnerable
about your
addiction and sobriety and recovery and
i would just be curious
what your greatest gift from that has
been and
if that has affected your comedy or
career in any way
so thanks okay they may you make them
put them on video
yeah they don't have to they can do
video or audio i believe we've just been
using video more recently because times
have changed and people like it like
that
yeah but i like what you gotta speak to
her to send the question in you gotta
put yourself together
for a bit you're gonna be going i might
be on the podcast i'm a
i'm a tight knot i'm gonna tighten up i
like she looks you put a church window
in the back for you that's secret
nothing
i'm joking but as you put all those
self-help books in the back for me
there you go very good what's that up on
the top what's that say
it's something something from hobby
lobby it looks like very
look at the bottom books can they can
the audience see this bottom books
bottom books
yeah they can see it yeah she got the
baby and who dude
she loves those turquoise titles and
she's got a oh she got purple on the
bottom turquoise white
white white and then dark on the top i
like that that's the dark arts
that's the organization right yeah um
that's a good question well i think you
and i have a connection i mean you and i
i mean i just invited you the other day
to an al-anon meeting yeah so i'm still
trying to figure out like
we didn't we couldn't figure out what it
was yeah that meaning is al-anon is
interesting
but that's like it's like you know what
all those meetings all the a
anonymous whatever they are it's just
like oh do you go to like
crossfit or you're going to 24 hour
fitness like you're in there
right emotionally right lifting doing
some reps
right and you gotta face
and so you're like hey you want to go to
allen i mean i go i know i'll go
yeah i know right the gym the mental gym
right yeah i go there yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'll find i'll find something to
take from there right
yeah mine was what's it for the earlier
question mine was
alcohol depression workaholism
narcissism and sex so all five of those
wow that's what they put they diagnosed
me with
they were like you need to you need to
work on all of these
i was like wow yeah and so when you go
like because
the only thing i've done is i went to an
eight-day facility recently
and then i've just been an aaa you know
yeah i would like to go to more kind of
longer term and just stuff because it
was really good when i went
um what do you what are some things you
really got out of it that you didn't
know about yourself before
well all right so if you my situation
was not similar to the duggar situation
but grew up very like
this is the way life is right and it's
very like
very there's a lot of shame how i grew
up
right so all these things you're like
you know you when i was
let's say like when's the first time you
ever saw like a playboy
oh let me think it was september and it
was uh
oh no how do you know it's september oh
it was september dude oh it was oh he
felt it and the leaves were changing oh
dude
i was changing brother i knew that man i
definitely
uh i was shedding our skin's brother but
yeah it was september and i believe it
was in the early it was in the 90s
okay what did you did you did you have
any context of that prior
did you did you no and so you saw i
didn't know why
this is am i is this bad what'd you
think
oh as soon as i eject out of my body i
thought
something's wrong with me okay where did
that come from
i thought well it came because i didn't
know anything i didn't no one had told
you information right i didn't have any
information so then when i did that
and it felt good but then it also it's
on my person
yeah yeah then the see the siemens on my
body
i felt dirty because you have to then
clean yourself up so i think there's
there was an element of feeling dirty
mine was
me and my brother were riding bikes over
these this dirt track this old
construction site that we had built
these jumps and stuff down the street
from my house
on uh lulaway and we were riding and we
i saw a playboy in the i remember this
like it was yesterday just like jen
just like jenny looking at you and i saw
it me and my brother saw it
oh and i and i i hadn't
we rode we were like a mile and a half
from my house we rode home as fast as we
could
and you already had you picked it up no
no we never even touched okay we didn't
touch it did he see it too yup we both
looked at we saw it
and we had no context of this we didn't
know
and so we wrote him as fast as we could
because we were like
we were scared of it or we didn't we we
were kids
and we i remember throwing our bikes
down in the garage we ran inside where
my mom
was doing something we were breathing
heavy and she goes what
where you guys been and we said
we hid we said nah no no no nothing
and that's why i go back to why did we
hide
why yeah why we didn't do anything wrong
we we
but then we and then you know what i was
you know you know the answer to this i
was laying in bed that night what do you
think i was thinking
about that i gotta go find that i gotta
go sneak now i gotta sneak back out
right and tell somebody i'm do and go
back
so now you're building up more secret
you're building yeah whatever your set
whatever sex is to you at this point
it's very
secretive and that and that it was from
that day until
35 years old that it was very
right don't listen if you just
like like like very and there's a lot of
and
that's a lot of christian growing up
christians a lot of like a lot of
youth pastors act like when's last time
you looked at porn and like
a lot of i had to report to my pastor
every time i masturbated
wow which is
oh that would take me a month it would
take me a month of straight talking to
the man like literally
we would have to have coffee delivered
hey this is yeah yeah yeah so you had to
go into the confession did that help
does that help alleviate some of the
uh or does it just feel like i'm
reporting how bad i
am or is there a a
part of the template of that process
because i'm not as familiar with that
process
part of the template of it is that you
there is some relief granted to you
well i i look we you all learn pretty
quick they're like all right well i'm
just not going to say
because if i'm if i say i'm not
down so i'm just not going to say
because it's a private thing anyway
right it's not like which
so then you're hiding then yeah yeah
yeah then you're hot and then so you but
but you
think things so anyway
fast forward until i was in rehab for
four months and i thought you know my
life is over because like a very
christian very shame-based very
to answer her question i got out
everybody dude was like dude we love you
man good to see you man i hope you're
doing well
that's right you're not gonna i think i
even said yeah can't wait to see you
back on whenever you come back to
memphis we'll be there and it was i'm
i'm telling you right now i couldn't
grasp that
because my whole life i lived with if
anyone ever
finds out the truth about you everyone's
going to hate you
and then everyone knew the truth about
me and they go
we love you dude everybody we all we're
all on the path man
let us know and it was more lovable in a
weird way it was on
yeah it's kind of where our relationship
started maybe yeah yeah yeah i was like
oh this guy's [ __ ] up too man yeah
what's up this is my buddy
yeah well you i think you felt very
safe with me because you could and
people did i was in the uh
i was in i was buying a car i was buying
a new car and this guy goes
hey man you john chris and he said my
girlfriend is a big fan he's just like
i just want to let you know man i uh i
struggle with porn too i get it i go
what i know i don't need i don't
i know i appreciate that you feel very
like yeah that we're all
out here together i think the penthouse
package out of this kia
i don't think i need this right right
but you do feel very you feel connected
connected somehow yeah yeah then you
were like oh man
and that's what i think a lot of people
relate to your podcast cause i go that's
i see myself in that right
i'm with that well and i think it makes
me relate to you man because
you just want to try your bet you know
you want to try your best and you're in
a world where it's really hard and
and there's a lot of and this something
we talked to jordan peterson about like
the level of capabilities
that these companies and these
organizations and these
uh talk about religious or no i'm
talking about no i'm talking about like
pornography sorry
oh yeah okay or not or like the
advertise the way that they have to grip
you
yo yes yeah so strong strong yeah
it's so strong man and it's it's
my relationship to alcohol like i've
been sober for
19 months almost but it it had to be
physically taken from me for about a
month and then i was like
i'm good right so when you when you
somebody says to you hey i'm going to
stop
sugar or i'm going to stop caffeine or
i'm going to stop drinking or i'm going
to stop
it's it's kind of disrespectful to the
human body it's so strong dude
it's so strong yeah and you say i'm
gonna start
whatever that chemicals is so strong
that you
you can't it's hard you can like white
knuckle it for uh for
a couple days maybe would say i'm i'm uh
i had my alcohol to be
physically taken from me and now i can
live without it yeah now you've been a
separate from a long enough you could
but that was a rehab is first of all
it's not practical it's expensive
it's it's in a yeah everybody can't do
that
so if people come to you or me and say
hey how do you how do i
get help my hand was kind of forced in a
little bit right i got
exposed and so i had to make a choice
then but i don't know what you would
tell
me two years ago
you couldn't tell me anything hey this
consequences of the
i didn't care right what do you tell
somebody that's in the dark
now man it's a great question i don't
it is yeah what do you tell them i
i said to my friends just be a friend to
that person
this is what makes me emotional just be
a friend to that person that when it all
comes down you're the first person they
call
that's it that's it
there's no
giving them a pamphlet about like the
dangers of teenage pregnancies
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah i'm
not even a teenager yeah or or yeah
i don't know yeah some guys are
unbelievable
yes but yeah trying to be there for
somebody
yeah that's it that's it and they say
and like if
if you say hey i'm gonna go to this i'm
gonna go
to uh i mean i feel like you've helped
me a lot a way say at a meeting in a
a new meeting is uncomfortable you don't
know where it is yeah that is in there
and you say hey i'm going to check out
this meeting you want to roll yeah
does it help now again but i'm
trying to walk to the light though right
that helps if you've got a buddy that's
out of his mind
what do you you can't really right yeah
i mean you almost have to go with them
you almost want to bring but you can't
force them no you can't force
that yeah no no no no yeah so you just
say
i mean i had a great talk about this
with chris deleo the other day you know
because he had a lot of
i mean he really you know he's really
struggled with sex addiction he talks
about it openly and i don't feel like
i'm talking about him out
outside of shopping yeah and there were
some things he even did that were kind
of like
just like broken bro code type stuff you
know yeah yeah
yeah and some of us just he was saying
look man i was so
into my addiction i did i thought
everybody was behaving this way you know
i didn't know yeah yeah and it's
interesting because it's like
you get the opportunity to have some
sort of affection or admiration from
women
that you never received never seen
before yes that you that you
i mean i remember if you remember the
jenny looking at you
i remember
in this girl's basement after a
basketball game at her
she was having a party with her older
brother i looked her in the eye
and asked her to go to prom with me and
she said no
oh i would have but i've i i have i have
a couple memories like that
right even in college or at frat parties
and stuff like that we just felt where
you
looked a woman in the eye and said do
you want to do
and they said no and that
that's hard so then then you become a
little bit you get a little bit of
success and then the
the the girls be like hey what's up what
are you doing it's like
right it's the all the pressures off of
you a lot of the onus is off of you like
but you didn't even know that
now they're coming to you right and
you're like what
this is my and but you you
when you're like in it you don't like
all the
all you do in rehab because all these
people were in there for all different
things yeah
all different type of addictions
something that well crazily i had a
friend who was in there with you
yeah really oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i
forgot about that he was there with me
dude he goes he's wearing all these do
you know
how many people you know but uh you were
younger 15. so the odds that there's
15 people meeting up in arizona for sex
addictions you know two of them are
friends with me
that's how we reconnected because i got
out of rehab i go
yeah yeah you go yeah that's my guy
today actually that blows my mind okay
so all they would do in there is try to
get you
to see it from the other side right
right so i
like one of my main struggles and still
is is narcissism behaving
i'm not a narcissist i have narcissistic
capabilities or tendencies
right which is different right so like a
narcissist would never go to rehab
right a narcissist would be like hey
maybe i need to get some help a
narcissist would never do that
right he would never admit that he has a
problem never right anyway so
like let's say for example we're all
meeting up to go to dinner at 5 30 in
the parking lot we're all gonna meet at
5 30 in the parking lot
i show up at 5 45. i'm like
it's we're just he's like well think
about it from the other guy's
perspective
this guy was on the golf course taking a
nap doing whatever
he got up change showered quickly to be
out there at 5
30. and he's standing there 15 minutes
nobody's there and then you stroll up
just willy-nilly eating a taffy you're
just out here whatever
you listening and singing a song kenny
chesney
look at it from that i go oh that makes
sense right
oh yeah i could i could see why
i would be pissed if i was him and
that's the thing with
chris and i'm not speaking out attorneys
but and me and everybody so you think
about it from the other person and you
go
oh yeah that person just came to your
show and they were just a fan of yours
and you're they're sitting with five
thousand people not the bragger however
many people are at the show
less than that i'm saying chris jones
and then and then the guy from up there
says what's up
right and if you're a little bit
insecure or a little bit a little bit
lacking in
any type of way and that you're gonna be
like yep i'm
yes yeah anyway that's not good that's
not good
for that person right well it's not yeah
it's kind of a
it used to be you would just have those
kind of feelings and
everybody would go home and they would
have people would have their imagination
and their hopes yeah there was
and then when you finally met someone
that filled enough of the criteria
and warmed your heart you would attach
all those moments of like
oh i admire i want this that i need
connection
you would attach them all to that person
and you would hope that that
that you guys together make it so good
right yeah yeah yeah and then now it's
like we get
so mad the second we have an urge or
someone else does we have the ability
to put the urge on to a blockchain
almost
yeah through instagram or social media
or on the dating site
or on dates yeah i gotta oh dude i used
to go to casual encounters right
i've ever even said this is that uh this
is
called gary place no this was on
craigslist
here's the crazy thing is that i just i
just said it was a place like it's a i
thought it was a
i thought it was one of those casual
like a phone number the ad comes on late
at night
yeah i know what that is and see if
because one of my problems in my 20s i
would have a date set up
and then
you good bro yeah just sin in my throat
building up it's the lord talking to you
bro
the lord babies in my mucus membrane go
ahead
or the or the devil's trying to stop you
from telling the story oh dude
i got post nasal devil um
you know nothing goes with sex addiction
and that sort of thing like a little bit
of blue chew on you
you got to keep it your wiener well
you see somebody get they got a sick
wiener it's sad
sometimes you'll see somebody holding
their wiener and they don't know what's
up or
you hear their wiener cough a little uh
that's bad that's not great what i'm
telling you about is blue chew is a
unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cyalis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost
just a little bit it's an online
prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations oh i know hey
you know something's wrong with my leg
or something near my leg
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days
i get them i get those blue chew hitters
daddy you know it
blue chews sildenafle and tidal eyeful
tablets
are chewable that's right
there's a special deal for our listeners
you should try it get your wiener well
try blue
chew free when you use our promo code
theo
at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping for them weiner uppers
[Music]
that's blue chew promo code theo to
receive your first month free
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast
let's face it when you're shopping for a
car insurance and home insurance it can
damn damn drive you nuts make you pull
your hair make you pull your eyebrow out
of your own ass
god you know you could spend days
looking up hunter to provide or
scrolling through thousands of policy
options this one that one this one come
on a scroll
here's a pamphlet it's too much
that's why when i needed my insurances i
knew where to win
the zebra can help you
z the zebra is the nation's leading
insurance comparison site
for car and home insurance in other
words they do all the shopping
it's easy you just get your insurances
the zebra pairs people with the
insurance company that's right for them
yep saving you an average of 922
per person on home and car insurance
combined shop car insurance without
shopping around make it easy to get all
your options in one place
for free by visiting the zebra.com
theo that's the zebra.com
theo support the podcast i remember yeah
i get on casual encounters because there
was the
opportunity to have affection for women
without any consequences
yeah and this lady i remember i met her
at a uh
cafeteria which is a bad sign out the
gate
like a school cap like a college
cafeteria or like a just like a cafe
tyria it had all it had it had that yeah
yeah it had a salad bar
it had buffet and bar yeah you would go
back with a new plate
or you need a new plate if you want a
new plate alright so it's upscale all
right okay yeah
but she and i met there
i didn't even know they sold tequila she
chose it right she was a few years older
than me
she said meet me at the cafeteria yeah i
meet her there
we have two tequila shots in this
like it was getting close to kind of
closing time so i think they had kind of
turned off some of the lights kind of by
the kitchen but it was still pretty well
yeah
yeah oh my god then we went back to my
apartment she
made sure every light was out in the
entire apartment
she even took a little placard like a
piece of paper or something that could
be a placard
yeah and she put it in front of like the
uh
playstation where the little light yeah
it was even blocked that
no light completely no light and then
but it was it didn't start like this so
she knew who what you looked like prior
she knew what i looked like probably
right
i don't know if she had like scars or
she'd been in some fires
okay i don't know and my hands i can't
tell really that good if somebody has
fire skin i think i just don't have good
like feeling hands you know
it's uh like i've felt it you would know
i think i don't
know maybe not it's like a scar isn't it
it's kind of like a scar-ish yeah
it would have to be pretty bad i think
for me to feel like if somebody's been
in a small fire i don't think i would
know yeah
yeah yeah but you know i mean i haven't
i don't know i could have been i could
have made love to someone that had been
in a small fire and have no idea
that's what i'm saying honestly i feel
that i feel that
but you're not you're not okay we'll
continue with the story so anyway
we end up making love dude and uh
pitch black pitch black
what's she wearing at the cafeteria full
long sleeves
she was wearing she looked like a little
bit of a rock and roll woman okay
yeah like she listened had listened to
rocks she'd been on the road a little
bit
yeah she definitely driven 200 miles to
[ __ ] some guy in a band
like she looks not the lead singer like
a she wanted the lead singer yeah but
who knows if she got him i don't know
she was all 200 miles and she was
attractive okay
all right there you go but but you knew
this before was there a photo exchange
private photo exchange okay but that was
like email yeah through email
[Music]
so that's what's crazy bro is to think
that what's crazy is to think that
that in my mind whatever whatever sexual
stuff has
you know whatever things had built up in
my head my
sexual like foundation yeah it led
it put me in that place where that was
kind of that was how i was
and you you kind of didn't it was a slow
progression and then you kind of found
yourself there
yeah but over a little little like
sacrifices over not sacrificed but like
yeah i wouldn't normally do this but
i'll do it and then you get then you get
there right
yeah and right there little things it's
like you know what i'll see what this is
about i've heard about it
let me just look it up a little bit let
me look at casual encounters
next thing you know later changing yeah
and then finally you're like okay now
i'm literally
walking across you know wilshire in los
angeles to go and meet someone at a
cafeteria
and you and but like
you no one
no one does acts wrong
nobody on planet earth yeah you say you
know the guy that
that's true this is a true story i think
so it's not a conspiracy
a guy flew hijacked an airplane fluid in
the into the world trade center
i can see it that's a true story i've
said i've said oh yeah
he bel that's he believed he was right
9-1-1
he believed he was correct did he not
right
yeah in his mind in his mind he thought
i don't know what his rationale was that
america needed to be taken out democracy
freedom
liberty the capitalism islam needs to be
number whatever it was
he's he and if that guy could convince
himself that that
is right anybody convinced himself of
anything
right anybody and so maybe if you were
like for that you were like
and and i can relate a lot i was like
i'm in a lot of i'm in a lot of pain
it doesn't the consequences don't matter
or i'm gonna
you're acting correctly to you
right in that pos in that you're like
you are and everybody is
if you're going to get on the internet
and trash taylor swift say she's a [ __ ]
or she's the word like if
people if you're going you are acting
correctly
to you right that she has a lot of money
or she dumped her boyfriend or her music
isn't good or she chose to be a public
figure
you have to tell a story before you do
that
right right because you're if it was
wrong you wouldn't do it even if you
murdered someone you shot them
and they'd now later you'd probably
realize oh goodness that wasn't but in
the moment
you were correct right for you they you
thought that they deserved to die
based on what they did they cheated on
your girlfriend or they whatever you
shot
you acted correctly right in the moment
and that's everybody and that's what's
scary and that's what rehab is like
think about
the the the 2000 people that are in that
world trade center that are at work
and then when you do that if you go into
starbucks
9 30 in the morning you scream at the
girl for not having your coffee order
right you have to get it out of your
head
that she is making minimum wage
she woke up at 4 30. yeah she's been
dealing with these
people for four hours
if you thought that you your body your
mind will not
allow you to scream at her
it won't right because but but when
you're and even if
you don't relate to the other person is
if i'm in so much pain
i have to ease this pain somehow i'm
going to take it out on
anybody you're acting correctly in the
moment and that all rehab is trying to
do is say
right think about the think about the
guy that has a family
that is in the world trade center think
and you go and if and if rehab
if the process of change is correct
and maybe not instantly but you go oh
yeah and that's the that's the process
of transformation
that that's the whole thing right yeah
perspective that's it getting a person
but if you're in a lot of pain
i would do at the time i would do
anything to to to
that closing that hotel room door at
night when i was on tour it was like a
prison cell dude
really being out on the stage and
standing ovations that was all fine
but when you that thing closes
it's you you're just sitting there yeah
you just sit
and now you're nobody you're a little
hungry you go down can i get a snickers
they're like
what's your code and you're like you're
helpless dude
and you want to ease i don't know why i
got into like one of my no anyway if you
liked it
you'd like to accept the lord please
raise your hand sorry
sorry my bad dude i got too deep dude
well i start to think what is my story
that led me to
because i i wonder if i you know i go to
some saa or slaa meetings and that's
sex addiction and sex and love addiction
we've been to a couple of them yeah
yeah we've been to some man and and and
it's not as big a program
um as other programs
but there's definitely a lot of it like
a lot of connection like
i think when i was young
i my needs were all met but you
when i was you weren't lack or you were
i wasn't lacking for any like i had like
you know we had food we were very poor
but we had things but
my mother had to work a lot but i think
my mother never
adored me as a child and i know that
sounds like a weird thing to say
and people were like boo hoo right sure
and that's fine
i i agree somewhat like you know i don't
want to dwell on it my entire life
yeah but where i notice it affects me is
when any ad or any opportunity for
adoration
yeah presented itself that's what i
needed
that was before comedy dude that was
this is before company this is from
being
the same thing you're like dude oh you
just got into this trouble a couple i
could not know
i've been this my whole life dude yeah
my life
needed extra where do you yeah i've
needed
a i just when attention from women
became available
i needed i remember my girlfriends
growing up i i was i was such good
friends with their mothers and all my
friends
i'm still good friends with their
mothers like yeah
i just want that that was all about yeah
there was just something like
and i also was kind of an i was real
sensitive kid so like yeah
and it's not a knock against my mother
you know she did everything that she
could do
it's just i i needed an adoration
i needed to be seen by a woman in the
eyes and like
like bored it you didn't need to be seen
by when you needed to be seen and that
was the easiest way to
to get it right like my there was a guy
in rehab
that he would uh he was like he's he's
like one of the richest guys in his town
right right and he was i don't know what
he was in for he's the richest guy in
his town
and we would uh everybody's addiction
kind of played out in its own way
so every every weekend when we left we
had to say what we're doing every hour
like i'm gonna wake up at nine i'm gonna
go to breakfast because because people
addicts get off track right if you
you're going to be at all these places
and you can do whatever you want but you
just had to tell them what you were
doing i mean you couldn't go to like a
bar like a strip club or but you and so
this guy
was the richest guy in his town just
relating to your story
every saturday he would go
to the uh to the car lot the the new
the dealership oh yeah and he he would
go in there
and he would get forward lincoln mercury
yeah you know the big ones
yeah yeah lincoln and he would get
pre-approved
and they said they all knew how much
money he had and he would walk around
that place like
oh getting getting like just like you're
getting it or i'm getting it from the
crowd
he got it by people knowing that he was
rich
yeah and that's like you said i needed
it from women you didn't we all have
this like
well now i need it from everybody for
comedy i need it from everyone
he needed and that was his way of
getting it and he goes well dude i'm not
doing anything wrong
i go well why don't you tell him why
don't you tell him
that you're going to the car dealership
and he never bought a car but he just
walked around there
and they knew how much money and it felt
like does that make sense
yeah it's to another guy you're like
yeah i go that's not my thing but
it totally makes i got god you need to
go
feel the thing that you yeah checks out
checks out
yeah and and wanting attention from
women it's also the tough thing about it
is it's also something that's just
in your nature yeah so it's not like
it's a cr like a foreign thing you know
it's like this
substance and this and i'm not
describing women as a substance but it's
this other
it's the other half of what it takes in
the world to make
yeah life you know it's this it's this
magnet
so it's also um well they said they say
it's similar go sorry finish your
thought
i can't well they say it's similar to an
eating disorder
where you have to eat but you know
if you've been working all day and you
stop by mcdonald's and get a salad
you're like is that in your addiction
no but if you're sad because your
boyfriend broke up with you and you eat
three double cheeseburgers now you're
eating
that's your addiction so sex
you you you can't be a monk and live in
the woods right you have to be
amongst women you have to and so if a
girl comes up to you after the show and
says
hey i love you i love your that felt
really good like uh like
like is that does that like
do it for you well i just notice if i
like i'm just attracted to
i get attracted to women pretty easily
you know yeah yeah
so like i want
you know i don't really know what it is
for me because i'm not like chasing sex
and trying to have sex every night so my
friends were like that yeah i was never
like that
i wasn't like that either i think for me
it was just more like i
i want you to like me yep
period and then if you're a female and
i'm attracted to you then
yeah heck i'd also like you to like me
more probably and if you're more yeah
well you're
you're very
i don't want to speak out out of tune
here but knowing you personally
that you're very
like into like after an uh something
happens you're very like
did they like me did how did that go
very
you kind of review it a lot like like i
always said with the race what do you
want to say when you texted me after the
race
yeah i went to the race and i didn't
really say hey to your family i remember
they were there
but but you so you went into your head
somehow and thought and i texted you oh
hey i'm sorry i didn't say to your
family which is but but
you you did the same thing remember when
i said about the ryman show i got you
were
oh yeah you you go but you don't you
can't be a comedian without
that right but like i go nah do they
they loved you and they know your friend
there's a lot of people there and you
said hi to them and they're
but you were like did they
like me right i guess in the end that's
what i'm looking for yeah do they still
like me am i still okay with them and
maybe for whatever reason you didn't get
the a clue that they did right and so
you're just following up to make sure
yeah whatever that what whatever that is
right yeah yeah yeah
that's what that's what does that leaves
your whole everything
that's right yeah and so that can be
also what people go to sex and love
addiction for it's like
it can be for affection it's not just
like somebody like sneaking around like
putting their hole through like a
bathroom yeah
yeah that's not it which happened at lsu
when i was there and i wasn't involved
in it okay and i do know who was
involved in it
this dude yeah this dude big henry and
this other this little white dude bro
with a uh
not a mustache but like um some kind of
long sideburns that almost came to a
mustache real stupid looking thing but
but you were that you heard about it i
mean i knew they were doing stuff bro
yeah yeah being real discreet uh
you know you can't be going to class in
the bathroom every day so
it's hot in here too guys the ac broke
um let's get another question that came
in here
wow look at this guy in bed ring that's
shirtless bro
jesus is there another person there oh
my god i'm have to take my penis off and
put it somewhere
oh my god the kid michaela
we were wondering our church got vbs
this week you got any good vbs stories i
know y'all both grew up
going to that vbs vacation bible school
well i didn't hear that game
gang baby that's unbelievable because i
was wondering what what
the what percent of my fans are your
fans and your fans or my fans would you
think a lot
say only probably 15 of your fans are my
fans
and vice versa yeah i think we have
different thing right yeah yeah
but but he what do you talk about vbs
uh i haven't talked about it much man my
dad you know what that stands for
vacation bible school yeah
yeah my dad would take us over there and
we'd make a lot of arts and crafts
it was arts and crafts every dude the
lord is in the glue dog oh man there was
but that was just the k the the there
were chicks there though oh 100
100 but they did they didn't your family
didn't know what to do with you during
the summer no
and they send you they did anything yarn
camp
anything dude horse cam yeah explorer
cam
yeah boy scouting treasure hunt nothing
doesn't matter
yeah take these kids reform pedophile
media
i wonder i wonder how like you know like
if you like
botany so this guy looks like a decent
man like a good baptist
guy if he's probably from the south so
then you get a step away
yeah i could see him at least a
pentecostal or one of those new churches
you get a step so the pentecostal he's
like a step and you keep stepping away
yeah then you get jehovah's witnesses
then you get
into like you get two then it's then
it's the snake you're wearing an iverson
jersey yeah then there's their snake
hand
then you go so i wonder how far away
from traditional christianity were your
parents that desperate to send you to
camp that they would have said hey
yeah yeah snake handling church
take the kids dude it might not have
been christian as much as it was
like take these kids no i'm dead
seriously
yeah dude oh you know like hey what are
you teaching them yeah
yeah it's free you're taking these kids
for free
i don't care what you're teaching them
right yeah
because some of those songs so southern
churches
it gets dicey dude it gets quick very
quickly
it gets real interesting and you're like
hey get get on yeah vbs
growing up was i used to i used to work
at them in college
yeah in college i went to one in new
orleans
i worked in the inner city new orleans
teaching at vbs really and in new york
city
i did one and i mean dude it was
there was no rules out there because
it's tricky because somebody else
when you work at a church and you're
like a missionary somebody else's
when when your boss is paying you but
it's not there
it's the human being was not set up for
that
you're like yo i'm gonna work in in
nicaragua but my boss is in louisiana
you wanna set the alarm no i don't no
i'm not setting the alarm tomorrow
dude that's funny my dad's family was in
nicaragua doing missionary work when
when his parents right where was the
money coming from i don't know
and there probably wasn't much money
back then i think it was 1910
[Laughter]
now here's a weird thing i did in
relationships i painted a chair at
vacation bible school camp
and gave it to a girl like 17 years
later as an adult
and yeah look if you want to
end the relationship and end up on at
least
a list in a woman's head some kind of
list
give her a chair you painted as a
child 16 years earlier
as an adult dry and also drive it five
hours to
her dude but again in your mind
you were acting right this guy randy
when i was in vacation bible school he
said
he was he was from the other church he
would come over he was like
he was a he had a red sports car and he
was
you know when you at that age you you
the guy's in his 30s late 30s 40s and
he's single he's cool but
now you're like why didn't this guy now
he's us
where was his family right yeah yeah
yeah looking back on it
when your youth pastor is 25
and hanging with us at on friday nights
where
right where are your who's your squad
right is it us and so this guy randy
would come and he was a bigger guy he
would always uh
make randy bro he would wear shirts oh
cool
in the to swim oh he would you would
wear shirts yeah but like
not a lot like darker like darker like a
black
black no white guy but black shirt oh
man you could see through the if you
know what i'm saying
okay so that's golden baller so he would
do like uh you know he went off to high
dive
and that was uh this is a real story
dude
fake plant but it'll i'm sure it'll take
well yeah
dang it but so when he and he loved
doing that oh yeah yeah but he would
always
he wouldn't come out every day but when
randy started walking up
all the kids knew he about to
it's about uh and he would do a huge
come on randy
but everybody went and he was like kind
of a uh a rogue
he wasn't attached to a church like
these are from first baptism
from first press randy just we was at
six baptist athletes
anyway so he said he said he promised if
every kid memorized
psalm 23 he would shave his head
at the end because he had like a law he
had like a long he was a
oh yeah dude yeah and he goes i will
shake my head
he's an organ donor yeah 100 this kid i
think his name was
nathan and james oh yeah two of my
buddies
if they could quote psalm 23 he would
shave his head
and this kid got up there nailed it
and he ran in front of in in front of
church
and it was an outdoor it was like in a
pavilion type situation oh yeah a lot of
pavilions yeah a lot of people
said they were covered but not at the
sides yeah
i remember the uh that's a funny like
this the
this is must have been before this lady
was working
me and my brother my older brother i
asked because i was going to put this in
my act
but i i never talked about it on stage i
texted my brother like a year ago and
asked him this is true we were getting
we went forward for prayer
are you are you familiar with oh yeah
you go to the front of the church if
they if your children
yeah if you're convicted about being a
sinner which we were the we were good
kids
right you know i said they were like
you're are you positive that you
whatever
we went forward me and my brother were
getting prayed for but this woman's
woman was attractive it was an
attractive woman oh yeah it touched me
yeah she was praying for us i mean pray
yeah yeah yeah shoulder
pray for us and i remember i never
forget this and this is before i knew
what the word meant
so she goes just bless these
boys be with like the gen they starts
general the prayer starts general
yeah walk with them teach them your ways
may they do your will
keep them out of trouble these type of
things and then as you go on you kind of
get more
confident you're hearing from the lord
right kind you start
kind of guessing
and she said i will never forget this
she said i just pray
that you i just asked that lord that you
would break the spirit of masturbation
in their lives
and we didn't know what it was no we did
not know what it was
well he didn't know dude i had to been
12 maybe wow 11 or 12. i was
homeschooled i didn't know
it sounds like a place almost if you
don't know anything about it and it's a
spirit
oh the spirit of masturbation like it's
it's like sounds like a ghost
like it's i we asked our mom on the way
home no
we asked her like what what it what it
she goes where did you
you know at youth camp she's thinking
right kids one of the kids yeah you're
out at the you're on the
during archery or the canoes and the kid
that came up yeah
no it was turned prayer
but think about it think about it from
her perspective if you're these two
my brother was older than me so if i was
12 he was 14. that's probably
odds wise yeah i mean
right right yeah she just guessed wrong
dude dude i remember biking over to my
friend's house like five miles because
they had porno over there and i'd go
over there and look
look at it dude i'd go and use his
bathroom for like two hours dude on a
sunday
just in there just absorbing porno dude
just like
i remember even just like i would lay
down and just put the magazine on my
[ __ ]
oh my skin and just absorb the porno
oh that's what you uh at the time
but that's what i needed man and then
somebody had chiseled a set of tits in
like a tree outside
back of our apartment building and
people would be out like on the bar
jerking off to it yeah i swear to god
man
and it was good looking man i mean it
was for
it was an artist he could have sold that
if it wasn't on the tree i mean
yeah it got uh it got like these
larvaes in it or whatever but i messed
up yeah they messed up the thighs
they got the larva yeah she used to be
hotter when she was you know
when she was in her prime yeah it was
varicose breasts after a while after a
couple years but the first year and a
half first 18 19 months that stuff was
out there
you'd see people out there man well you
did you did it was our mount rushmore
dude
what what city huh what's it covington
louisiana
off of mcgee street praise god i bet
that's still there and we used to do
peeping tommen too and that was big when
i was
again you that was just like you got to
differentiate
curiosity versus right
because i saying we're like that we you
just like look
to see but that you weren't dude i
remember my buddy and i one of my
closest friends would sit there and sat
there naked once i'm under a blanket
okay not same
yeah yeah you might be on you don't know
this one but yeah and uh
and we're just like touching each
other's shoulders and stuff and it was
hella gay bro we didn't know at the time
you didn't know yeah we wasn't being gay
we was being children
that's the difference yeah because that
they always say when there's when
there's a
an in a difference of an imbalance of
power
yeah that's when it gets like someone
that's your boss someone that's a parent
someone that's age
some kind of someone that like yeah this
was even stephen
yeah so then yeah yeah yeah which is
true which is also tricky because
once you come into pow or you come into
influence or you come into something
right and then it's all you
automatically granted that without even
realizing you that's it maybe they
should it just should come with like hey
you got
it also comes with this so just be like
you don't know when the transition
happens you're like oh now
i remember jay moore talking about uh
right you're like now do women like me
just
like is it it has nothing to do with me
now now it's
different there should be some sort of a
little they should send you a mail or
something that says hey bubba
now you're different now like you just
need to take this
into context like if a chili's
if the chili server hooks up with the
other
chili server there's no problem
that's th that's a saturday that's two
for one that's yeah that's plus dessert
yeah but when the manager
or the boss hooks up with the waitress
which happens all the time or like maybe
that's not a good example but like
no yeah then you that you can't that's
the imbalance that can't do that
because you because she's if you say hey
do you want to come over
she's you're you're her boss right well
the weird
for some people the power never really
changes you're just excited to finally
have a way to
to meet women or you like women and
you're excited about getting to see them
or be naked around them and now it's
like [ __ ]
now you can't do that yeah it's like
again when you're the waitress and the
waitress that's fine but that now
now all of a sudden i see he's he's
right now now what about these text
messages that we sent each other
yeah we're like whoa that's scary to
anybody dude if a girl came out like
dude i there there's escorts out there
that i've texted some real sh
you know probably some poignant
information
you know yeah and not knowing the nudity
picks i don't send nudies yeah yeah but
um
but stuff yeah but things like if i
would be ashamed
you know i might be a little proud of
myself but also
you know because the spelling depends on
the screenshot yeah
but there's definitely like some combos
you'll be like man
and the world doesn't care the world is
more about like well let's see the
embarrassment
more than about what is the content
what's going on with this person
you know yeah yeah they remember that
that uh
when at the race the race so you know
i've i've made jokes about like the
mayor
mayor cooper yeah i've said like at my
my comedy shows the mayor's corrupt or
like because he's raising taxes or
whatever it is i made jokes about him
i go do we have some great comedians in
this country are we i do nashville's got
some amazing comedians nate bargatsi
theovan mayor cooper
like like but then at the race
he came out and did like the oh yeah
and they booed him i heard that so
and i immediately like rehab if it does
anything it'll move you towards empathy
yeah and i go oh i don't i i don't like
this
this is a man i saw him i look i didn't
make i can't but i look i go this is a
guy that
now he might be he might be corrupt or
he might but he he's
trying to sir i don't know but we can't
we this is not the way
right and and i felt i've felt empathy i
go i don't
i wanted to dm him and we're like hey
dude
what does it makes me cry to think about
like i was i don't right i was there
sorry how that probably felt i could
understand how that felt and i go i've
made fun of you on my show i just want
to let you know that
i've been through my own stuff and i and
we didn't deserve that
right that crowd is probably of a lot of
conservatives in the crowd i would guess
maybe that wasn't he shouldn't have
taken that gig right he was probably
doing to try and grab some face with
conservatives
yeah yeah yeah sure get back in with the
city but politicians are strategic and
he canceled races at that track for
all during covet oh well and so maybe
yeah yeah yeah so then they knew that
they
yeah they all knew it was not the move
but i remember i went to the
the hawks game the hawk sixers game
about a month ago in atlanta
and ben simmons plays for the sixers
yeah kid is
a phenom i remember he played at lsu
dude an all-star right this kid was
a million million dollar contract and
and and in the playoffs kind of
yeah duncan passed it pat and he was
very timid he's very
right and i remember being there
crushing him dude and then somebody was
like i read on espn or something like
22 years old and i go
i feel some kind of way about this now
now this kid's
in his hotel room with a phone
right but that's where we that's where
it gets weird is when we
do we it's it's tough that's the tough
thing about being a comedian you're
doing
because you're like it's tough to be
empathetic
but also want to be able to just rip on
stuff and be funny
and be a sports fan and be up and be
bill burr said that
remember burke chrysler asked him if you
ever wanted to meet the president he
said no
because i never want to meet him because
if i meet him
then i can't crush him because i
empathize i i
know donald trump he's a buddy of mine i
can't
right and that and that's but that's not
the right way to live
you know what i'm saying yeah it's not
struck you dude it's tricky
it's true that's look i think that's one
of the battles of everything but also
it's like we've also created an
environment now where there's constant
information about everything so there's
so much stuff to be empathetic for
yeah that you almost get exhausted that
you can't be like the the refugees
you're like i don't
yeah i mean i felt even on the hospital
on this past weekend on some of the solo
episodes we'll talk a lot about like you
know try and
listen to things that are going on with
people and i love it you know and i love
like because a lot of people all call
privately and just chat and stuff and
and you know it's important to me and
and you can tell sometimes that it's
that it's feels good to them to connect
with somebody
but but you can't take on everybody
sometimes having to yeah it's like
it's like yeah you feel like how i can't
do
you can't do everything nobody can and
sometimes we we want to and sometimes
like
like i notice i'll text people and ask
how they're doing sometimes done that to
me
and the truth is i do that i feel like
because i mean one i care i want to know
i want them to know somebody cares but
also i wish people did that to me
yes yeah we all do those things you know
so i remember
i wasn't in my deepest shame when i was
in the real real darkness we had a a
green room that overlooked the parking
lot
of the sh of the show and it was like is
it by hampton inn
it was uh it depends on the night was it
in baton rouge
no it was in the south though maybe a
jackson or some city like that okay
and i remember our green room had a
window looked out over the
and it was it was an hour before the
show and that line was
hundreds of yards and these people were
so
oh this is their super bowl dude this is
and i was like
i was like i was like and i was in a
dark dark place
in my and i couldn't watch it i go you
got to take me out of here i can't
i never experienced that before but i'm
a comedian all i want to do is that
right to go like this is my guy dude
this guy makes me laugh we drove four
hours
yeah we got the tickets here's the
tickets there the truck
this it's gonna we're ready and i hate
i couldn't my shame wouldn't allow me to
why like what is it you think like
you're saying like what
well i don't i think it was like these
these if if
i felt worthless so when people drove
four hours and say we love you
that was hard for me to because i saw it
used to be just a big crowd now i saw a
guy
and his wife and their friend and i go
they made it
i go i can't look at this dude this is
or like dude the the lines wrapped
around the
i go it's hard for me to me it's hard
for me to feel like it's hard for me to
see that i mean something to someone
when you don't when you're working on
meaning something to yourself
or when i felt like i think i felt for a
long time that i didn't mean
anything to anyone yes and for me that's
a lot of it
and when someone says someone watches
this podcast
connects with you and says hey
the closest theo is coming to me is
eight hours i'm gonna drive
to see him does that would that would
that dm make you nervous
oh it just makes me feel like
it almost makes me feel sad a little bit
not for them but it just makes me feel
not
sad it makes me feel
it makes me feel like i'm never going to
be able to do something to repay them
that they've they've
saved your life kind of in a way yeah or
just like a
man they're they're doing this like man
i'm not worth that
you want to say hey well next tour or
don't i'll come don't
do it yeah yeah yeah right don't do
don't go out of your way for me but they
but they
right but to them it's a different right
they you know their world you have to
let them have their joints
like that and that thing inside of me
don't go out of your way for me it's
like
all you ever wanted was for someone to
go out away from me god that makes me
emotional dude
like and look man i'm not saying any
stuff like i'm not like
you know i'm not in some debbie downer
thing or anything like that
like but everybody if the comedian or
not everybody could relate to
that but it's like yeah i think i always
just
somebody said hey theo of all these
comics of all the shows
we're choosing you right and even if
it's a
a monetary exchange you're giving them a
thing it's it but right
it's like man it's just it feels like
you want to see you want to tell them
that you're not worth that but they have
decided you are like if i went to right
and then it makes me
almost jealous that i wish i could
decide that i'm worth that yeah you're
like
which is when i got out of rehab
everybody said do we love you we i go
what
if you went to prison tomorrow
i remember when i was in rehab there's a
month or there's three weeks where
there's a blackout period you can't talk
to anybody right
no but and i got after really wow three
weeks and i thought my life i thought my
life that was when i was
as close to wanting to end my life
because i just but after three weeks
there's a whiteboard
and when you have a letter or a note
they write your your name and your last
initial so
three weeks i heard nothing and all of a
sudden i walk in
john c
and i and grant think about i was in
wickenburg arizona with with a bunch of
dudes in your buddy
and i didn't know knew nothing of just
trying to they tell you when to go the
bathroom when to eat when to sleep
and it said john c and i went up there
and they him a little is a little like
you know when back in the day when like
you called the office and the boss is
gone but they write a little
samantha called from from accounting
right
give you the little away whatever that
was and they hand me this message
and i looked at it i was writing the
atrium there was that
this is like one of those like moments
you remember forever and i said
you said your parents are coming to see
you your parents are coming
you didn't know they were coming
no i didn't know they're coming but but
i i thought i ruined
uh i thought i go why would my i i
embarrassed the family name
i my dad's a pastor my mom works at the
school at the christian school
my dad's in politics john crist is on
fox news cnn usa today
what do you mean and they cared and it
was like for a week that came for a week
to like and that's all i ever wanted my
whole life is my parents to say that
like they ca
and i was like and i wanted to tell him
tell him
i'm not to come tell him i'm i'll be
done and whatever
you know what i'm saying and all it was
like i was so
shocked by that that they wanted to do
that
i think but what you're this is your
parents right why would they why
are they not where did you get that idea
like where did you get that idea that
people wouldn't
it just i don't know i was yeah i don't
know where that that thing comes from
where did you where did you ever get
that idea that your parents
when you were in the most amount of need
this is their child
that is struggling where why
would you think that they wouldn't come
to see you
i don't i don't know that's what that's
what the whole process was that's how it
landed on us
yes and every day dude every day
i don't want to make a bigger deal about
this as it is but like
you know if you're in rehab a guy would
get a piece of mail
once every three weeks maybe someone get
a piece of mail except for my wife or
from a child or something
every day stacks of
mail from and i didn't know these people
really they
they either through my management
company or through my
family or a friend of a friend people
were like just stacks of mail dude and
all these people
didn't really know me that well i mean
my family did but it was people like
hey my daughter is the gm of the club
that you worked at in denver and she
likes y'all and and i have the same
story and i need to tell you
to that it's a i have to i'm compelled
to get this message to you wow they were
so moved
but it's it was all people that have
been to the dark right
looked the devil in the eye it was all
of those people and to to for me to
refuse
i don't
to not let them love you is right
it's almost the same right
and that's the yeah yeah yeah when
somebody says hey theo
comedian or not you're my guy dude he
needs some
he's like that can't be and now we're
always thinking someone wants to take
something from us
someone wants to yeah you know meeting
or not that thing
whatever that is that's really bad and
you go it can't hit me it's like what do
you mean like if i'm not
something extremely special
you can't just you'll never see me
that's what i always felt like never
like unless i stand out
like as much as possible and go over
right that will never be seen and and
what and what happens if you're never
seen
that's a death sentence yeah for a guy
like me death sentence oh
i think it's a death sentence for any
human yeah and what's scary is
when everything happened to me like
people were saying the most horrific
things about me on the internet and but
everything happened it was
it was stuff like
things came together yeah getting some
lewd information with you yeah yeah that
i was like sexting girls
sexy girls there wasn't anything no it
wasn't a yeah
non-traumatic and nothing non-consensual
nothing it was just a guy
being a comm and and but also with
christian when i was working in church
when you were working in churches and
stuff like that
everything has a different taboo which
is fair right and i say
that's a good point i've said it's
interesting if you work at a company
and they said you can only wear jeans on
friday and you wear jeans on thursday
and you get fired
that's you knew the rules right of the
company either that might be a bs rule
but you knew i knew when i work in
churches that you can't get hammered
and bring girls to your hotel room right
and i did that right and so that if that
and you get fired
fair not no moral is this a good guy or
a bad guy those are the rules
spoken or unspoken i took the job right
fair yeah it's a good point yeah if it
had just been comedy clubs and stuff it
would be different but when you have
churches and stuff it's different
sure which is like the worst
the worst
you know i'd read all these comments and
people saying these most horrific things
yeah it's horrible but you know that my
buddies joke about this my buddy's in
the group text
he goes you know what you know what
comment hurt the worst this is it's kind
of funny but it's kind of
like some guy goes who's john crist oh
man which you get that totally you
you're like it's all but
but people are talking about me if
donald trump is on the front of the new
york times
he wins he wins no matter what
it's saying nobel peace prize or
got caught with a hooker yeah if he's on
the front
people are talking about him as a
narcissist
you win and somebody goes
who is this it was it crushed me dude
you're like that's tough dude that's
tough yeah i think when i was growing up
there was such little
i had a sister that was real sick she
had a liver disease when she was born so
she needed a liver transplant
and uh
and so she got any affection my mother
had she got and she got to be around
nurses like people that real caring
yeah yeah yeah all a lot of attention a
lot of attention yeah yeah yeah
and the rest of us just didn't get it we
just didn't get it
uh and also here's one thing i want to
say about that kind of stuff is like
i could have gotten it but i didn't feel
like i got it
so that's another thing this and that
like
if you ever want to talk to your parents
about stuff like one way to do it is you
can
that's a great point i didn't feel this
is how it felt to me so that way it's
like you're not attacking them like
and they're not the end they're not and
they're not the enemy like uh you're
like hey like my pastor
who would ask me if i masturbated like
i would like to talk to him now be like
hey this seemed like a little shame
based
but also that guy was trying to
help yeah he was trying to help he now
it wasn't it wasn't but you're
apparently like
my dad was like oh he was gone a lot at
conferences you're like yeah but i had
eight kids i needed to get the money to
right it was it kind of wasn't you you
didn't get the love the way
you wanted it right you wanted your dad
to play catch with you
right you wanted a certain type of
serving and it's they didn't have that
that's it you wanted some thousand
island oh we got his ranch at this house
and the crazy thing they didn't have it
also because nobody
ever gave it to them that's where you
also are like a lot of us are suffering
the g
the genetic the third generation of
something that happened generations ago
um my my my buddy isaac
when i went i was homeschooled first
eighth grade then i went to private
school
and i was always hanging with him and he
would uh
every time his parent they would leave
him out hey you're going to the movies
leave the car
off the phone off to you they would go
we love you
isaac i love you and i never no one ever
said that to me in my house no one ever
said
john i love you no it just wasn't
did my parents love me my parents my mom
said she when i was in rehab she
i said she said she would give her life
for me she said that to me
and i believe that right and she would
but does that make sense i never i go
how come
and you get a little bit of a scar maybe
because you're like
what why didn't you tell me that yeah
but yeah but their parents never that
right they don't know yeah they don't
know but so here's the thing then if you
have children you could tell you know
get specific with them sometimes about
how you feel if you think that they
may not know and because i think in my
house i think my mom always just assumed
we
knew also that of course we love you
theo right of course i love you of
course we're
a family unit we never knew any of those
things we felt like we
you were on your scavenging out on your
by yourself yeah to get and
and and so then yeah yeah but you got to
get if you didn't get that
and i felt like i needed to get
everybody in the world to love me so i
could get my mom to love me
by default look at all these people that
are at my shows right shirley
and then what's odd what's very odd
which is like our relationship is like
you burn your life to the ground and
that's when your parents show up
but they to be fair they came to every
comedy show they could within
six hours they would come to they you
know what i'm saying but that's what
meant the most
is when they came john c oh man dude
that should be my new name dude yeah
yeah
yeah it's interesting once you're in
kind of some of the recovery world it's
interesting to have somebody else to
talk to about this kind of stuff
you know so i appreciate you man i
appreciate you being willing to
just even when you and i are out of here
or whenever wherever we are you know i
feel like we're always willing to kind
of talk about some of this kind of stuff
we've been we've been in in to be fair
we've been in the light and the darkness
together
we've been in meetings together oh yeah
and then we also been oh yeah
trying to holler at girls i was trying
to buy drugs that one night at that
freaking bar remember
jesus christ thank god
but we but but you you you're like one
lady got her glasses stuck in her nose
ring that lady was out of her mind
but you don't have any kind of like uh
yeah when it's when it's past the point
of like
i'm not here to get anything from you
and you're not here to get anything for
me because
whatever i have you have and whatever
you have i already have so if you said
hey and we and i and i've said probably
in the past year that we we both kind of
come and gone from the darkness to the
light
you know there there there are periods
where
i'm still i struggle oh yeah heavily
shattered yeah and you go yeah you know
you're doing but you're not doing
anything
no no no no you're just challenging your
own kind of
newer set of boundaries and you just
like
hey do you want to go to a meeting you i
know when i say no and then i start
you know i start isolating yeah you just
want to do you just want to kind of
not be in the light but every time we go
to a meeting it's like
that's that's whatever that is that's
that's christ man that's christ yeah you
make a joke out of it but it's not but
it is
seeing people connect seeing people
touch that's remember that guy at that
meeting
that last one he was crying yeah sitting
right next to us growing up so happy
because his wife it was better
grown man had gotten a divorce ballin
dude and he
went how many people were that meaning
50 there's a lot of people there
and he when he started talking about i
don't know what he was talking about and
he just started he fell apart man
yeah and you gotta wonder how many
people are walking out at this
in this everywhere tonight just
this close close to
coming undone dude you know well
especially in today's world
we want to get anything that feels human
yeah it resonates you with you in a cord
that's on
that that's a connection that that's of
a higher power
when that adult man broke down and
started crying because his
the wife that had left him was was she
doing her health was doing better
something like that yeah she was i don't
want to compromise
and i don't want to compromise anybody
there's a couple years sober yeah and he
goes i'm so
proud of and i'm just so great that
she's healthy and i
that's too much i mean it's not too much
but it's the
it yeah yeah yeah and what but you can
serve him by just by being there and
listening
it hits that heart harp dog and say get
all the way in that goes all the way in
but that plays that hard heart
um john chris if you if you guys haven't
seen a lot of john's videos uh they're
so f
dude i am so envious dude you
kyle dunnington there's a couple guys
and i'm just so envious um
i love kyle that makes such creative and
entertaining stuff and
uh go check it out you have a new tour
that's going on too this fall
yeah fall tour every every theater
you're coming to i'm probably going to
the week before the week after
cool man and some even bigger ones i
think i know you're going to be on in
baton rouge too
so i think i might try to go down and do
that go down with my family remember
that one time you came on my show
uh-uh yeah he did i it was my show oh
with the uh
that was yeah you know i think he's just
too edgy yeah
i didn't either i go didn't did you tell
him that it was like a church crowd i go
no he's a comedian dude i mean he said
they joke about the guy
about by the fence oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i shouldn't have told that one but but
i'll say the same thing dude go see theo
show man you'll love it dude
thanks brother i appreciate it man love
you bro thanks for coming on and uh
yeah we'll have to hit a meeting soon
same to you brother gang now i'm just
floating
on the breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
[Music]
but it's gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself on my eye
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my
[Music]
i will stories it just